Welcome back everyone this is going to be my video
for the new house of the dragon first look video
the hbo release for the game of thrones prequel
series there are several new characters filming
some special scenes from the events of the dance
of the dragons which is the story that the prequel
will be based on i will be doing all the episodes
for the game of thrones prequel series just like
i did for the main show so if you're new to
the channel be sure to subscribe to get those
i will do some special giveaways when we get
a little bit closer to the show coming out too
there are still several other game of thrones
prequel series and spin-offs that they're working
on set during different time periods that i'll
mention at the end of the video but this dance of
the dragons show is the first one we'll actually
get episodes for and currently the expected
release date is around april spring next year
2022. i believe they're looking to occupy the same
time of year that the original game of thrones
series had there's also some practical reasons
for when they have to start airing episodes in
order for the show to be eligible for the emmys
so that's why april is probably when it'll start
they'll have 10 episodes per season like the main
show originally had for at least the first several
seasons and i believe that hbo and the showrunners
have said that they have at least a five-year
contract in place for a five-season plan just
hoping that it will run longer than that but
right now they're planning for five seasons on
all shows when they go beyond a certain point they
have to renegotiate the actors contracts and all
the creative talent everybody that works on the
show so if they go beyond five seasons for some
of these game of thrones prequels it'll be the
same situation you also probably saw that they
signed george r martin to a special development
deal for high eight figures i think it's like mid
high eight figures for him to stay on and help
them develop all these prequel series and guide
the writing in a way that he didn't in the last
couple of seasons of game of thrones he helped
them write a lot of the earlier seasons of game
of thrones but after about season 4 he ran into
issues with trying to finish winds of winter which
he's still trying to finish now he's back on board
helping them guide all these other prequel series
they're developing just to make sure that they
don't go off the rails but the first look teasers
they just released reveal some cool details about
what they're filming right now it doesn't mean
they're filming the opening scene of episode one
right here they filmed the scenes in the episodes
out of order but this is all footage from episode
one and obviously the footage of the opening title
scene there is the targaryen sigil fire and blood
because the dance of the dragons is all about the
targaryen family but they group the previews in
three different photos because they represent the
main factions of the series or they will become
the main factions during the dance of the dragons
conflict that serves as the backbone of the series
there is the up to the actual conflict it's sort
of like the main show on game of thrones you have
the war of the five kings you have the battle for
the iron throne then we had the war for the dawn
so you have a series of smaller conflicts bigger
conflicts the lead up to all that and then the
aftermath so the actual dance of the dragons
conflict itself the actual targaryen civil war
only lasted for a couple years so i know people
were kind of wondering how they going to turn
that into a five season show well part of the way
they're gonna do that is not speed running the
plot skipping over every possible thing they can
just to put it into perspective if they had done
everything from george r martin's song of ice
and fire novels on the main show it would have
taken them like 15 to 20 seasons to get through
all the plot but the actual targaryen civil war
the dance of the dragons took place about 170
years before the events on the main show just
to chart the timeline so none of the characters
from the main show were alive during this period
with the exception of the night king although
technically he's not alive he's undead maybe
a couple of the white walkers were around rounded
this period that were still around in present day
but for the most part the white walkers that you
see serving underneath the night king are actually
all gilly's brothers remember craster made the
pact with the night king in exchange for clemency
so he gave him all the sons that were born to him
and gilly was one of his daughters that he later
married it was this whole big thing but a couple
years after the official end of the dance of the
dragons both brynden rivers the bloodraven aka
the three-eyed raven and maester aemon targaryen
his nephew were born maester amen was born about
23 years after the three-eyed ravens so with the
exception of the children of the forest who are
all extremely long-lived before they all wind
up dying on the main show the three-eyed raven is
technically the oldest living person on the planet
that we know of remember the night king does not
count because he's not alive but the night king
during this period was relatively dormant during
the events of the dance of the dragons he is
around he is up in the lands of always winter but
he's not quite as active as he becomes during the
events of the main show so there might be some
references or easter eggs towards the end of
whichever season winds up being the last season
of the show but i don't expect them to reference
the white walkers that much we will have starks
they will say winter is coming because that is
their house motto starks tend to say that but the
main factions that you see here are olivia cook is
alicent hightower and rhys ifans is otto hightower
her father alicent became the second wife of king
viserys who's being played by pattd considine
if you haven't seen him he's not in any of these
previews he's not around for the scene they're
filming right now but he is alive when the show
picks up he remarried to her after his first wife
died without leaving him a male heir but before
she died they did have a daughter together who you
see in these pictures that's Rhaenerya targaryen
the woman you see standing next to matt smith's
character who is daemon targaryen he's the younger
brother of the current king viserys the first the
important thing about these two factions though is
that otto hightower and prince daemon hear matt
smith's character were bitter rivals in king's
landing otto hightower used to be the hand of
the king but was fired essentially by viserys
for demanding that he name all of queen alicent's
children the presumptive heirs to the throne
over his oldest daughter rhaenyra and even though
king viserys went so far as to make a proclamation
naming rhaenyra his oldest daughter his heir
presumptive prince daemon his younger brother
actually saw himself as the presumptive heir
because he was the closest living male relative
to viserys so even though it might seem weird that
they're suddenly a faction together in the dance
of the dragons like if he wanted to be heir over
her why is he siding with her in this big war of
succession we have to think the enemy of my enemy
is my friend but all through her life king viserys
raised renera training her in matters of state
taking her to small council meetings basically
teaching her how to be a good ruler so had there
been no targaryen civil war and she ascended the
throne she actually probably would have been a
great queen but had he wanted to daemon would
still have legal cause to challenge her claim
to the throne if it had come to that eventually
had viserys not gotten remarried and actually had
a son but eventually viserys does get remarried
to alicent hightower and within a couple years
of that she does give him a son who they name
aegon ii this other character that you see here is
lord corlys velaryon known as the sea snake he's
part targaryen through his velaryon bloodline the
velaryons are a vassal house of house targaryen
sworn to dragonstone so they have a lot of the
valyrian blood flowing through their veins as well
the sea snake is actually a really cool character
he's actually known as the richest person in
westeros far richer than the lannisters most
of his wealth comes from trade the sea and
expeditions that he goes on they call him the
sea snake he is basically master of the seas
you have to imagine him as like a boss level
upgrade to someone like euron greyjoy without
being the crazy douchebag pirate that euron was
the seat of the valerian house is on driftmark
and that's where this place is where they're
filming this scene but even though he's pictured
separately he's not a different faction he's
essentially part of rhaenyra's faction in the war
the dance of the dragons so the two main factions
are mostly referred to as the blacks in the greens
and no that's not a reference to the color of
their dragons because there are many different
colors of dragons alive during this period alicent
hightower represents the greens and rhaenerya the
blacks because as their relationship at court
began to sour over time and people started to
pick sides in the matters of succession there was
a great tourney held to mark the fifth anniversary
of king viserys remarriage to alicent. alicent
showed up at the tourney in a green dress rhaenyra
showed up wearing a black dress so the two main
factions were named for the color of their dresses
because essentially this is a targaryen civil war
being fought between princess rhaenyra and the new
queen alicent so you have a war of the princess
and the queen and the rest of the seven kingdoms
picking different sides but they didn't start out
as enemies they were actually friends for a long
time once alicent was old enough she was actually
sent to court and grew up alongside renera they
had a relatively positive relationship for most
of that period and it really wasn't until king
viserys named renera his heir then later remarried
to alicent had a son with her but then did not
name the new son aegon ii the new heir that's
really when things start to go south between
the two women so he has a new wife with a male
heir which traditionally you would pick the male
heir to be your successor but he still wants
the daughter from his first marriage to take
the iron throne when he dies and it's really his
death that sets off the actual war like you have
the death of robert baratheon leading to the
war of the five kings it's a similar situation
king viserys the first dies in that same year
is when the actual dance of the dragons begins
because when he dies by that time his son aegon
ii had actually grown up a little bit he seizes
the throne for himself declaring that because he
is a male heir to the former king his claim to
the iron throne is stronger than rhaenyra's who's
a woman technically he's not wrong but kings were
allowed to break those rules when it suited them
they could name their own air if they wanted to
but there was always ways to legally challenge
that after the king's death and it wasn't a
situation that happened very often with one
important exception which i'll explain because
it's related to the scene that they're actually
filming in all these preview scenes that they
released the scene that they're filming here seems
like it's related to the funeral of elena velaryon
the daughter of corlys velaryon the person here
in the other preview she died about nine years
before the actual conflict of the dance of the
dragons in around this time is when this big chain
of events happens where a bunch of heirs to the
throne wind up dying kind of complicating things
further leading to the dance of the dragons but
the reason why this scene is actually really
important is because it foreshadows some of the
events that will happen on the show the story of
lena's life actually plays out similarly to what
will eventually happen to rhaenyra's character
they both had similar problems with the
line of succession in the iron throne
because for a little while lena was actually the
heir presumptive to the original king jiharis
the first but her father the former heir to the
iron throne died while she was still in the womb
so instead of letting the throne just passed
to her once she was born king joharis the first
named his next oldest son the heir prince balon
and his son wound up being paddy considines king
viserys the first who succeeded him a little
while later so all these heirs to the throne
all these different people are dying and coming
along within the span of about 10 years leading up
to the events of the dance of the dragon so it's
getting really really complicated around this time
but remember that when the show picks up in season
one king viserys paddy considine's character is
still alive my early prediction is that he's gonna
wind up being their sean b ned stark of the series
being the super important character when the
show begins because he's the current king he sits
on the iron throne only for them to kill him off
really quickly after the show picks up setting off
the new old battle for the iron throne in the
same way that robert baratheon's death former
king and then ned stark's death set off the war of
the five kings only instead of the war of the five
kings this time it's the war of the princess
in the new queen or the blacks in the greens
the other really big difference on a practical
level between this show and the main show when
that picked up is that originally if you remember
the way they treated the dragons like each season
you saw a little more the dragons the dragons
got bigger this time we start out with really big
dragons and there are many dragons not just three
special effects have also gotten a lot better so
imagine the way they portrayed the dragons in the
last couple of seasons it'll be a little bit more
like that when you see giant aerial dragon battles
happening during the actual war the dance of the
dragons the actual conflict itself we'll get
a much better idea for how they're gonna pace
things out and where things pick up in season one
once they drop that first trailer they'll probably
be some footage later this year because they just
started filming for the most part the schedule of
when they release stuff when they release trailers
when we start seeing episodes airing is going to
be the same as it was in the original seasons
of game of thrones let me know in the comments
if there are any special videos you want me to do
for the series or big questions that you want me
to answer and if you guys didn't see it there's
a big game of thrones reunion happening during
the marvel eternals movie we have jon snow being
reunited with robb stark richard madden remember
they never actually met each other after this
moment on the show and they said the next time
we meet you'll be dressed all in black because
jon was taking the black and kit harington is
playing the black knight during that movie you can
click here for my eternals trailer video that big
marble phase 4 trailer video and click here for
all my other game of thrones videos in house of
the dragon videos thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe and i'll see you guys tonight!